this was more than just a listening
experience these virtual labs take
courses from being a listening
experience with maybe some pencil p-sets
to you know your hands are active so you
know hands on brain on right and what
people Rhaenys turn on it they remember
it ever wonder how we go from the
building blocks of atoms to creating
things like Amazon Cloud and how
educators introduced the architecture of
digital systems to future engineers so
here I was I was writing on the Hong
Kong subway and some young adult comes
up to me and says I took your MITx
course I'm sorry going wow I mean this
is you know welcome to chalk radio a
podcast about inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare today on the podcast were
diving into the world of six double O
for computation structures this is an
MIT course designed to teach
undergraduate students how digital
systems are engineered some students
come to the class with prior experience
in programming and some understanding of
how computers are structured but others
come knowing little more than how to use
a browser through the iterative teaching
practices of a team of instructors this
course manages to engage all of these
students in learning this cutting edge
information today I'm speaking with one
of the key educators in this course
senior lecturer emeritus Christopher
Turman will run through what it takes to
connect and educate an audience whose
experience might vary from complete
novice to virtual professional in our
conversation Turman shares his insights
on the evolution of this course over the
last twenty years and how its current
design is so effective at engaging its
broad student base we'll start off with
Sherman's own story of getting engaged
with computation structures so how did
you become interested in computation
structures well in the early 70s I was a
college student trying to earn my way
through college and so I was the
computer operator on the third shift for
the campus computer and I was in the era
in which you
only afford one and since watching the
blinking lights was boring I pulled out
the schematics for the computer I was
running for the for the University and I
started trying to figure out how the
computer worked ever since then it's
been sort of a lifelong interest in
figuring out how do they actually put
together these components to make a
machine that can do computation what
kind of background experiences so the
students bring related to computation
it's all over the map it's all over the
map so some of them will come having you
know programmed computers for a long
time and maybe even know a little bit
about how the computers are structured
on the insides other people have not
done beans and so they come with
interests but no background at all so
how do you structure a course to meet
the needs of people with diverse
backgrounds like that right so to handle
really diverse backgrounds you have to
have a huge range of materials so you
need something that somebody who just I
need to start at the beginning you need
a beginning for them to start at and for
somebody who sort of you know passed the
first half of your material you need a
second half which will engage their
interest so I create a huge I think of
it as a buffet there's lots of dishes
and you can start at the beginning of
the buffet and and sort of you know pick
it up from scratch or you can say I skip
the first couple courses and I'm ready
to dive in you know sort of in the
middle of the conversation somewhere so
the I think the real key is having a
huge selection of materials to draw from
and that's I think one of the hallmarks
of six double O 4 has been that you know
we have every possible way of learning
the materials so not only for different
backgrounds but for different learning
styles there's sort of an emerging best
practices out how how to explain
material to people for the first time so
you know you want to do a short byte
sound bytes video bytes you know those
short segments of learning where you
introduce a single skill or a single
concept and then you take a moment to
actually you know give them some checked
yourself questions so the idea is well
you in theory you just listen to this or
watched it I'm going to ask you some
simple question
not puzzlers there does if you
understood what I just told you on the
video then you can answer them and I
think the students appreciate it
everything is much more bite-sized you
know we both know is you can imagine
pushing play on a 50 minute video you
know long about minute while I'm gonna
say 37 but I long about minute six
you're going to be maybe I should check
my email while I'm listening to this
okay it's you know keeping things short
and sweet plus is asynchronous another
way of state they get to choose their
time in place this must be just such an
exciting time for you as someone who's
really interested in the scholarship of
teaching and learning and then the
emergence of these digital tools to
enable those that learning through best
practices I can can feel your enthusiasm
for kind of the era that we're in yeah
well you know those of us who teach at
the university level you know we get
handed a piece of chalk and be told to
teach you know unlike the teachers for
your kids in elementary school who have
actually gone through a program teaches
them how to teach we're just said here
at teach and so it's all anecdotal it's
all trying to remember how people taught
you
finally we have you know the online
courses are providing a real educational
laboratory we're able to try out
different techniques we're able to you
know make fairly accurate assessments of
how well did that just work you know
whether it was an exercise or a video
segment or a design problem and so we
can actually you know do a/b tests
within the same cadre so you know it's
pretty neat having a lab I mean as a
scientist and engineer even though
hypothesis test it you know through a
bunch of experiments we can really do
the experiments with the MITx platform
and so that's been great
[Music]
let's talk about learning in the
classroom and teaching large lecture
classes what strategies do you have for
keeping students engaged well that's
interesting because we have so many
different materials really the only
students who come to lecture are the
ones who had you know for whom lecture
is how they learn I was such a student
so the people who were there are not a
draft arm either so they're prepared to
be someone engaged by a local
presentation so I have a well-developed
set of materials that I present in class
that have sort of been debugged for
having not too much or too little a
progression that most people can follow
this is a very relaxed sort of
experience you know I tell jokes I tell
stories from my career and it's
interesting to me how you know when the
P students are making comments at the
end of the semester and the evaluations
many of them say well I really like the
story so it's you know after boring you
with technical details that's fun to say
and then when I tried to use that you
know this following thing happened and
all of a sudden they're sort of cooking
up saying oh man you know and I think it
helps them remember the related good it
does not you think about what you
remember from lectures is almost never a
technical nugget it's no joke they told
or an accident that happened or a
mistake that was made and so it's faint
if there's this concept called fluency
mm-hmm which is basically how smoothly
things are going and and and everybody's
nodding but no you know your mind is
starting to drift because it's all so
it's actually good to try to put a
little disfluency into your lecture to
actually have a you know you stop and
you tell a joke or you made you make a
mistake or you drop the truck and say
darn and you look at the floor or and
here's what I like to do as you walk out
from behind the lecture table or lectern
and you approach the audience and you
can see them sort of like wait his
escape does anything that sort of
switches up you know the sort of I'm
just going along with the flow here so
you know making you know little flows
that have things that change make a lot
of difference in keeping people sort of
things I was curious about the teaching
team behind a course like this so I
asked Chris to tell me a little bit
about the team of people that make a
course like this work we have a little
cadre of people who are instructors I've
been sort of part of that cadre every
semester for a very long time but we
have other you know people who come in
from the outside or in recent years the
department is added election you know
lecturer resources so there's another
lecturer associated with it and then
faculty come in so it's and though they
provide a little depth to the gene pool
but then we have graduate TAS who teach
recitations okay and we have a student
undergraduate TAS and then lab
assistants so there sir we have this
whole hierarchy they've all taken the
course they've all loved it so you know
sort of like me there's an enthusiasm a
sort of bubbles out yeah and the
students actually you know I sort of
listed things sort of well I was going
to say top down and I'm not sugar
lecturers were at the top but their
instructors are at the top but the
students actually prefer the other thing
which is they actually you know asking
in LA it's not very intimidating and the
students maybe they just took it last
semester and so they have fresh in their
minds what it is they needed to do in
order to get whatever it is they're
trying to get and then you sort of work
up the hierarchy to you know get an
answer if people below and that way
you're only asking questions of the more
intimidating people when you're pretty
sure that no one else has the answers
right what's the role of the online fora
in the course for helping students feel
comfortable asking questions and how do
you monitor it how do you run it
productively this is something that
educators sometimes struggle with to me
it's a it's a wonderful asset for the
first time I'm able to make a thoughtful
answer to a question and have a hundred
and eighty people look at the answer
instead of one and then the next person
has the same question you say well I
just
I get up with a large class you can't
spend 10 minutes for each of our you
know 300 people so it's a great place to
ask questions and so many of the
questions are look I read the material
I'm still not getting it I need an
example so the students I try to make
students feel very comfortable asking
this never there's nothing no cost they
can ask anonymously so that removes some
of the barrier I see Paul 2017 we had
about 2,500 contributions to power the
average response time is about 20
minutes and so a lot of us who are
involved in the core sort of have a we
put the notification of postings on real
time and so we get an email right away
and I think the fast response time
really reduces the frustration level of
the students there's nothing like being
stuck on something right and saying I I
wish I could ask somebody
well for the first time you can say wait
I can't ask and I can get an answer and
the students really really appreciate
that so it the forum has really I think
changed student's level of frustration
when they get stuck they know it's being
stuck it's just a 10-minute process not
a two-day process
[Music]
let's talk for a minute about the lab
experiences in the course so students
get hands-on experience doing digital
design yes um could you talk about a few
of those experiences and also does that
take place here where we are right now
well you can do it anywhere it's
browser-based so there's no software to
download you're just just on the web you
go um you know 20 years ago I gave you
software to download on your computer to
do this stuff you know man mind that was
everybody's environment was a little
different oh you don't have the latest
version of that library well you can't
run this but if you update your library
you can't run that and it was it was
really a nightmare
so yeah packaging up these lab
experiences in a way that they can be
used by people around the world
you know I saw here I was I was writing
on the Hong Kong subway some young adult
comes up to me and says I took your mitx
course yeah and I really love doing the
circuit stuff and I didn't have to
download anything and I'm sort of going
wow I mean this is you know it is
interesting to be stopped by people
right and you know they start talking
about how this was more than just a
listening experience so these virtual
labs are actually take horses from being
a listening experience with maybe some
pencil psets to you know your hands or
active so you know hands on brain on
right and what the old brains took on is
amazing what they know remember it right
one of the distinguishing and most
interesting parts of this course is that
the learning is greatly enhanced by
deductive reasoning in fact the ability
to apply prior knowledge to solve a
problem in front of you is one of the
main skills students come away with from
this class lot of students aren't very
good at taking the information they do
know and using it to deduce the next
thing to try or the next thing to test
and sort narrow down where the problem
is so something you have to learn how to
do is to be organized about taking
something that isn't working a
complicated thing so parts of it are
working but something isn't and trying
to work back from both ends somewhere in
the middle it does
work and so that's a skill that you have
to practice for a while and so I you
know I we try to help with that steel
it's sort of neat to watch them make the
transition from coming in and sort of
answer focused to leaving sort of like
okay you can ask me anything because I
actually know how to do things I mean I
from scratch I can not only recognize
the right answer when I see it I can
actually make right answers that's a
very but people feel empowered when they
can do that
we'll close out this episode with a
moment from the interview that really
struck me because it captured how chris
strives to humanize the learning
experience in six double-o for how he
understands that students are whole
people who bring their lives into
classroom spaces doctors have this
saying you know treat the patient not
just the disease and so when students
are struggling with material I find you
know it's often the case that there's
issues that are not just you know what's
the technical concept or skill that
we're talking about and so I learned
over the years to make myself as best I
can
accessible to students who need to talk
about their life as a student their life
as a person here at MIT and you know
everybody comes with a bit of imposter
syndrome so you need to you know help
students deal with that a little bit so
there's a lot of issues that aren't on
the syllabus and six double-o for that
affect how they do in 1604 and I've
learned that it's good for me to invest
my time in helping them you know
think about talk to their larger issues
I'm not very good at writing
prescriptions but you can sort of listen
you try to offer a bit of perspective I
think what's interesting is that over
time you begin to appreciate it's going
to put effort into something it might as
well be the best it doesn't cost you any
more even better and it's sort of
interesting to me how many people say oh
you know I'll go give that lecture but I
won't really care no no you know that's
that's not the right approach you may
you should actually say look if I'm
gonna spend 40 percent of my time each
semester teaching students would it make
sense to be proud how best right I think
everybody comes to that you know the
more you're here teaching the more you
utilize that if you're interested in
learning more about computation
structures you can find the course
materials on our website at ocw.mit.edu
and if you're an educator check out our
educator portal at ocw.mit.edu
you so much for listening if you enjoyed
this podcast please consider subscribing
and rating our show until next time I'm
Sarah Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare